einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu zdf heute live beherzt kommt mit
macht die temperaturen sinken was
bedeutet das für unseren umgang mit dem
corona virus wie verhalten wir uns da am
besten um möglichst gesund und gut durch
die kalte jahreszeit zu kommen
darüber wollen wir sprechen gerne auch
mit euren fragen und kommentaren zdf
heute - live at zdf.de lautet die
adresse und unser gesprächs gast im
studio ist susanne herold professoren
das muss ich mir jetzt noch mal genau
angucken für infektionskrankheiten der
lunge an der universität gießen und am
dortigen klinikum leiterin des
schwerpunktes für infektiologie ziemlich
kompliziert einen schönen guten abend
hallo und wir achten natürlich auch hier
im studio auf den gebührenden abstand
frau herold mit welchen gefühlen schauen
sie denn jetzt dem herbst entgegen wir
haben ja gerade schon so ein bisschen
das szenario skizziert gemischte gefühle
oder wie sieht es da bei ihnen aus
medizinischer sicht ja in der tat
zurzeit mit gemischten gefühlen
wir haben es bisher im sommer auch ganz
gut geschafft durch diese zeit zu kommen
und deutschland hat das vorbildlich
gemacht da sind wir beneidet wurden von
vielen anderen staaten in europa aber
auch natürlich aus den usa und wir
müssen jetzt zusehen dass wir diesen
vorsprung nicht verspielen
und dass wir uns gut vorbereiten auf die
kommende wintersaison das wird ja so
sein das wir natürlich jetzt wieder
vermehrt in geschlossenen räumen sein
müssen
dadurch wird die infektionsgefahr
steigen und wir müssen schauen dass wir
uns eben ganz besonders gut weiterhin
das können wir nur immer wiederholen von
unserer seite an die aha maßnahmen
halten und das können wir jetzt im
detail noch mal besprechen was das
bedeutet wunderbar das werden wir auch
gleich machen aber bevor wir uns dann in
die fragen vertiefen wollen wir noch mal
ganz kurz schauen wie sind denn momentan
die infektionszahlen
wie verhält es sich mit den anderen
relevanten daten in deutschland mein
kollege jan frederik fischer mit den
einzelheiten dazu der sieben tage
schnittes nach einem anstieg zur zeit
relativ stabil
zuletzt haben sich 1760 menschen neu mit
den crooner virus angesteckt erhöhten
infektionszahlen durch viele corona
tests klar das ist eine erklärung doch
auch der anteil der positiven test
steigt also die positiv rate im moment
liegt die bei knapp 1,2 prozent der
höchste wert der letzten wochen
dabei stecken sich immer weniger
menschen im ausland an sondern direkt in
deutschland der wert der
durchschnittlichen neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner steigt in vielen
bundesländern die top 3 hamburg bayern
und berlin
der kritische fünfziger grenzwert wird
in vier regionen gerissen wie etwa hier
in hamm und wer infiziert sich vor allem
die 15 bis 34 jährigen alarmierend
jedoch bei den über 60 jährigen gibt es
wieder mehr erkrankungen und die lage in
den krankenhäusern dort ist die zahl der
fälle in verbindung mit corona zuletzt
stark gesunken und liegt im moment
konstant bei 5 prozent
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
derzeit 309 personen davon beatmet 164
wichtig ist auch laut rk ii lag der
anteil der todesfälle zuletzt stets
unter einem prozent
dann versuchen wir doch noch mal diese
zahlen so ein bisschen einzuordnen da
war natürlich jetzt recht viele dabei
wie ist es allgemein wenn sie jetzt die
infektionszahlen in deutschland sehen
haben sie da ein gutes gefühl würden sie
das als positiv bewerten
es gibt ja natürlich auch noch den
aspekt dass einige ihrer kollegen sagen
na ja auf die infektionszahlen alleine
kann es eigentlich nicht ankommen
sondern es gibt auch andere parameter
die in die bewertung mit einfließen
sollten
schwere verläufe todesfälle etc ja genau
es wurde ja eben schon gesagt in dem
beitrag dass die zahlen in den
krankenhäusern auch die schwerkranken
patienten im moment noch relativ wenige
sind wir sehen allerdings in der tat
jetzt vermehrt aufnahmen nach und nach
wird es so ein bisschen mehr aber wenn
wir jetzt nur auf die schwere der
erkrankung gucken oder auf die schweren
fälle dann werden wir demnächst ein
problem kriegen also es ist ja auch die
idee jetzt zu monitoren wie viel
intensivbetten sind frei und danach
irgendwelche maßgaben für draußen
vielleicht abzuleiten das finde ich
schwierig und kritisch es kommt für mich
tatsächlich darauf an wie die
infektionsraten in deutschland sich
verhalten wie schnell die jetzt auch
steigen möglicherweise oder ob man die
mit den aktuellen maßnahmen gut in den
griff bekommen kann
wir hatten jetzt zwei faktoren nämlich
einmal die öffnung der schulen und
zusätzlich die reiserückkehrer in den
sommerferien oder aus den sommerferien
heraus da haben sich zwei faktoren jetzt
potenziert und wir sehen ja auch
steigende zahlen oder jetzt relativ
konstant hohe zahlen und wir müssen
jetzt gucken dass wir da nicht weiter
steigt wie verhält es sich mit dem
verhältnis von jung und alt wir haben
gerade im beitrag gesehen momentan vor
allem die jungen betroffen aber das kann
ja dann irgendwann eben auch an die
alten weitergereicht die älteren so ist
es genau gesehen relativ niedrige
mortalität seien im moment weil die
natürlich gerade
bereich der jüngeren bevölkerung
infektionen haben die mittlere infektion
das mittlere alter der positiv
getesteten ist so unter 40 jahren im
moment weil wir eben viele infektionen
in schulen haben unter jugendlichen und
unter den reiserückkehrern die ja
besonders jetzt eher oder sind eher
jüngere menschen die reisen und aber es
ist genauso wie sie sagen dass man
natürlich aufpassen muss dass die
infektion jetzt nicht wieder vermehrt in
die risiko populationen hineingehen und
das kann man eben einfach nur verhindern
indem man die infektionszahlen
konstanten möglichst niedrig hält
gucken wir mal über den deutschen
tellerrand zu wenig hin haus in
frankreich momentan ein großes problem
16.000 neuinfizierte an einem tag so war
jedenfalls die zahl gestern da steht
deutschland im vergleich sehr gut da was
macht deutschland so viel besser und
wird das verbleiben
ja deutschland hat von anfang an sehr
sehr stark kontrolliert über das
öffentliche gesundheitswesen und
versucht einzudämmen also
quarantänemaßnahmen implementiert und
angeordnet wir haben relativ viel
getestet und konnten da auch relativ
früh weil auch früh die pcr in
deutschland relativ flächendeckend gut
etabliert war auch dann infektionen
erkennen und entsprechend am anfang auch
gut noch infektionsketten eindämmen
wir müssen schauen dass das so bleibt
ich glaube das ist auch ein vorteil den
wir gegenüber den anderen ländern hatten
dass wir sehr früh reagiert haben und
dann sehr schnell reagiert haben und
dass in deutschland die ad agents an die
vorgeschriebenen maßnahmen oder die
empfohlenen maßnahmen sehr sehr gut war
das hat uns geholfen durch die erste
phase der pandemie sehr gut
durchzukommen gleichzeitig haben wir ein
sehr gutes gesundheitssystem wir haben
vergleichsweise jetzt zu italien viel
viel mehr intensivbetten pro
einwohnerzahl gerechnet
insofern konnten wir uns auch gut
vorbereiten und das war auch wichtig
dass wir uns vorbereitet haben denn
wären wir unvorbereitet gewesen hätten
die auch die menge an intensivpatienten
oder einen schwerkranken patienten nicht
so bewältigen können wie wir es konnten
am ende
deshalb waren die maßnahmen wichtig und
wir sind so gut durchgekommen weil wir
diese maßnahmen getroffen haben und weil
wir uns rechtzeitig gut vorbereitet
haben wir sprechen gleich noch ein
bisschen auch über die reisetätigkeit
also über die grenzen deutschlands
hinaus ich will kurz noch auf die masken
pflicht eingehen weil das ja auch ein
thema ist was viel diskutiert wird bei
uns zum beispiel rolf schuster schreibt
auf youtube mich würde frau herolz
meinungen zur maske interessieren
schützt die maske wirklich so gut gegen
viren und ist die maske bei falscher
handhabung nicht sogar kontraproduktiv
das vielleicht auch gerade noch mal vor
dem hintergrund dass ist ja inzwischen
auch eine masken pflicht zum beispiel in
münchen
draußen gibt auf stark besuchten plätzen
ja das masken tragen ist absolut
hilfreich das sollten wir wirklich auch
weiter so durchführen wir haben ja
gesehen im sommer dass das geholfen hat
wir konnten die infektionszahlen extrem
drücken und ein wichtiger faktor war
dass masken tragen die haben am anfang
nicht so genau gewusst schützt der
normale mund nasenschutz nur den anderen
vor mir oder hab auch ich in schutz
mittlerweile wissen wir dass
wahrscheinlich auch der der die maske
trägt also auch wenn es nur den normalen
normale mund nasen schutz ist und nicht
diese dicke sp2 maske auch dann wird
wahrscheinlich der träger geschützt
zumindest zum teil und ich kann nur
empfehlen dass wir das weiterhin auch so
durchziehen auch draußen
man hat ja eigentlich immer gedacht an
der frischen luft sei man relativ sicher
ist es ein trugschluss gewesen nein an
der frischen luft ist die übertragungs
wahrscheinlichkeit sicherlich geringer
weil wir luftbewegungen haben und es
gibt ja mittlerweile mehr und mehr daten
die schon darauf hinweisen dass das
virus auch über eurozone übertragen wird
also nicht nur über direct röckchen die
man jetzt beim sprechen oder so von sich
gibt sondern auch durch die erosion
das sind ganz ganz feine partikel die
sind sehr klein wenige mikrometer und
die stehen länger in der luft also wenn
man der luftbewegung hat sind die
natürlich auch eher mal weg aber dennoch
es ist sicherlich so dass auch draußen
die möglichkeit besteht dass solche er o
sohle dann immer noch da sind und man
die einatmet und sich darüber infiziert
und auch deshalb ist es masken tragen
auch draußen sinnvoll
jetzt ist ja der herbst traditionell der
jahreszeit in der man öfter mal stift
oder hustet einfach weil man sich im
normalen effekt vielleicht geholt hat
was ist denn jetzt dieser zeit angesagt
also wenn ich jetzt symptome entwickle
wie soll ich mich dann verhalten
das wird uns jetzt tatsächlich in der
erkältungssaison auch in den kliniken
vor eine große herausforderung stellen
das zu differenzieren
am ende muss man sagen man kann die
symptome der korona infektion nicht klar
von den symptomen einer anderen
erkältung durch eine normale erkältung
wieder in anführungszeichen normal oder
von einer influenza grippe virus grippe
unterscheiden
ich merke als betroffener auch keinen
unterschied ja wir würden das sicherlich
nicht merken es gibt ein paar relativ
spezifische symptome für corona
infektion ich will jetzt gar nicht näher
darauf eingehen weil am ende wird es
tatsächlich schwierig das im einzelfall
zu unterscheiden das heißt also wenn man
solche erkältungssymptome hat ist
natürlich immer die frage kann das
niveau einer virusinfektion sein oder
nicht und das zu differenzieren wird
auch für uns relativ schwierig das muss
man dann durch kann man in den kliniken
nur durch entsprechende tests machen auf
die tests kommen wir dann gleich auch
noch zu sprechen also der herbst das ist
klar der ist unter anderem auch
reisezeit die herbstferien stehen vor
der tür aber das mit dem reisen ist
momentan natürlich alles andere als
unproblematisch es gibt sehr viele
länder auch innerhalb europas die
zumindest regionen haben die zum
risikogebiet erklärt worden sind
einzelheiten dazu von meiner kollegen
kollegin miriam dallinger
die herbstferien stehen vor der tür doch
reisen ist momentan nicht einfach die
bundesregierung hat die liste der
risikogebiete verlängert neu ist zum
beispiel dänemark die region um
kopenhagen gilt nun als risiko auch vor
reisen nach prag wird gewarnt tschechien
es bis auf zwei regionen nun
flächendeckend betroffen
schon länger auf der warnliste steht
wien jetzt ist auch vorarlberg dazu
gekommen
in frankreich wird neben paris jetzt
auch vor reisen in die bretagne und die
norm und die gewarnt neu auf der liste
steht portugals hauptstadt lissabon und
auch städtetrips nach dublin gelten nun
als risiko italien war von corona
besonders stark betroffen steht jetzt
aber nicht mehr auf der liste
spanien ist weiterhin das einzige
eu-land das komplett als risikogebiet
gilt damit ist nun die hälfte aller eu
staaten betroffen nur zwei von
deutschlands nachbarn nicht polen und
luxemburg so da können wir gerade noch
den hinweis geben kurz vor der sendung
kam die nachricht dass auch luxemburg
inzwischen ganz tschechien und tirol zum
risikogebiet erklärt worden sind von der
bundesregierung frau professorin herold
würden sie diesen herbst verreisen und
wenn ja wohin also ist empfiehlt sich
tatsächlich zur zeit einfach nicht zu
verreisen sondern zu hause zu bleiben
es ist einfach so dass das risiko steigt
das hängt natürlich immer so ein
bisschen davon ab welche art urlaub man
macht wenn man jetzt irgendwie ein spaß
urlaub macht und mit 200 leuten im club
feiert ist es ganz fatal wenn man allein
oder zu zweit irgendwo wandern geht es
ist was anderes aber dennoch würde ich
aktuell tatsächlich jedem raten oder
auch für die allgemeinheit einfach das
beste wäre jetzt zu hause zu bleiben
oder in deutschland urlaub zu machen in
regionen wo das videos eben im moment
nicht kursiert und da sind sie einer
meinung mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
sich geäußert bei uns im moma und wir
hören mal ein wasser genauer gesagt hat
grundsätzlich heißt der risikogebiet
reisewarnung für
raten ab von nicht notwendigen reisen
und urlaub fällt im zweifel nicht
zwingend notwendigen reise ins ausland
jedenfalls man kann ja auch urlaub im
inland machen
ich weiß dass das sehr hart ist für die
reiseveranstalter die reisebüros und
natürlich auch für die bürger die sich
im zweifel auf ihren urlaub gefreut
haben aber jetzt zweimal erlebt
stichwort ischgl winterurlaub und im
sommer das durch reiserückkehrer auch
infektionen stärker wieder nach
deutschland rein gebracht werden
und ich finde für herbst und winter
urlaub weihnachtsurlaub sollten wir
daraus eben auch gemeinsam lernen für
herbst und winter urlaub sollten wir
daraus lernen haben sie der große
hoffnung dass die deutschen lernfähig
und willig sind ja ich meine das ist wir
haben gesehen dass diese große
gemeinsame anstrengungen die wir gut
wirklich sehr gut gemeistert haben im
april und mai diesen jahres dass das
sowas geführt hat und das muss sich
jeder einzeln einfach noch mal vor augen
führen das ist eine gemeinsame
anstrengung und wir können das schaffen
die infektionszahlen weiter niedrig zu
halten und man kann einfach nur an die
verantwortung jedes genau klaren appell
nochmal von ihnen es wird reisenden ja
auch nicht leicht gemacht
reiserückkehrer müssen jedenfalls einen
test machen wenn sie aus einem
risikogebiet wieder kommen was sonst
noch wichtig ist für betroffene reise
haben wir auch noch mal kurz
zusammengestellt bei der rückkehr aus
einem risikogebiet mit dem flugzeug oder
dem schiff muss eine aussteige karte
ausgefüllt werden damit das zuständige
gesundheitsamt über den aufenthaltsort
informiert ist bis spätestens anfang
november soll das auch digital gehen
alle urlauber müssen sich in quarantäne
begeben
seit mitte august besteht zudem eine
testpflicht der test muss spätestens 72
stunden nach der rückkehr aus dem
risikogebiet erfolgen
ein negativer corinna test kann die
quarantänezeit verkürzen
ab oktober auf fünf tage ja jedenfalls
nicht ganz unkompliziert ich würde gerne
den fokus noch mal legen auf die korona
testsieger rauschen angesprochen worden
sind da gibt es also unterschiedliche
verfahren pcr des antikörpers
ein bisschen schwierig für den laien da
den überblick zu behalten was muss dann
der verbraucher da letztlich eigentlich
zu wissen
es gibt verschiedene tests wie sie sagen
am sensi tiefsten und am besten wirklich
am genauesten ist der pcr test der ist
eigentlich fast so gut wie immer korrekt
der den sätzen die auch die ganze zeit
ja schon ein
dann gibt es den antigen test das ist so
ein streifen test meistens der
funktioniert wie so eine art
schwangerschaftstest und misst aber
nicht die genomsequenz des virus das
gehen wirklich sondern misst einfach nur
eine oberflächenstruktur und er ist
wesentlich wenig genauer ist aber
natürlich schnell und wir setzen ihn
aber in den kliniken noch nicht oder
überhaupt noch nicht routinemäßig ein
weil er eben eigentlich zu ungenau ist
im moment und die antikörper test das
wissen wir die weisen nach ob eine
infektion stattgefunden hat im moment
wissen wir noch nicht so genau wie wir
positive tests einordnen sollen wir
wissen ja noch nicht so genau wie lange
die immunität anhält und was das
bedeutet obwohl täter gleichzeitig sehr
guten immunschutz bedeuten oder eben
nicht weil es da auch verschiedene
antikörper gibt die man bildet ja
insofern ist im moment die pcr noch der
goldstandard wie wir das nennen also
beim pcr tests gab es heute auch die
meldung da fördert die bundesregierung
jetzt einen schnelltest der in weniger
als 40 minuten vor ort dann schon
vorliegen soll
was halten sie von diesem projekt das
ist sicherlich sehr sehr gut wenn wir
das in ausreichender menge zur verfügung
haben wir setzen das aktuell schon ein
in den kliniken das braucht ein eigenes
gerät für diesen test
wir sind allerdings limitiert weil die
produktion nicht so schnell vorankommt
dass wir also nicht genügend material
haben und wenn man danach helfen könnte
wäre das wäre uns extrem geholfen dann
könnten wir das auch vielleicht im
öffentlichen gesundheitswesen in der
breiten testung irgendwann einsetzen
dann haben sie ihn sehr sehr genaues
ergebnis innerhalb von 40 minuten bis
eine stunde das wäre natürlich auch für
entsprechende folgende maßnahmen wie
quarantäne oder eben nicht quarantäne
hervorragend das würde ich also mit
aller macht unterstützen wollen sind das
dann auch dann tests die teilweise
selbst durchgeführt werden können von
den menschen oder ist es immer so dass
zu medizinisches personal dann
erforderlich ist also im prinzip braucht
es schon trainiert das personal man
braucht ja auch eine maschine in denen
man den test reinstecken kann der dann
das ergebnis die dann das ergebnis
ausspuckt sozusagen also das würde schon
an standorten stattfinden wo
medizinisches personal ist aber wenn das
natürlich in testzentren steht in
vielleicht im gesundheitsamt und vor
allem in den kliniken in den
notaufnahmen wäre uns extrem geholfen
ismael schewe über youtube erreicht uns
mit der frage frau herold wie wichtig
ist das sonnenlicht und eine gesunde
ernährung zu stärkung des menschlichen
immunsystem naja schaden wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig schaden
wird es nicht es gibt so ein paar daten
dass infektionen günstiger verlaufen
wenn man einen guten vitamin d spiegel
hat dafür braucht man sonnenlicht also
insofern ist das immer nicht schlecht
jetzt im winter wird es natürlich
sowieso schwierig draußen zu sein und
sonnenlicht abzubekommen unterstützt
hilft aber wird sie nicht von der
infektion schützen wenn sie sich
infizieren
sprechen wir noch kurz über das thema
impfung was versprechen sie sich
persönlich vom tag iks wenn es den denn
dann demnächst mal gibt wenn also ein
impfstoff vorliegt bis dann auf einmal
alles wieder so wie vorher oder wie muss
man sich das vorstellen
also es wird sicherlich nicht am tag ich
so sein wie vorher denn wir müssen uns
überlegen wir wissen nicht genau wie
viele immun wieviel immunität wie lange
besteht das heißt wie oft müssen wir
nach impfen brauchen wir mehrere
impfdosen wie effektiv wird er im stoff
sein wird er alle infektionen verhindern
dass es gar nicht so wahrscheinlich
oder wird er vielleicht infektionen auch
in manchen bevölkerungs populationen
oder gruppen nur reduzieren also dass
man verminderte schwere hat das müssen
wir alles dann entscheiden wenn der
impfstoff da ist was ein weitere frage
ist wie schnell sind denn genügend
impfdosen für im prinzip der
weltbevölkerung ja vorhanden und wie
wird die verteilung aussehen wie schnell
können wir überhaupt die menschen impfen
dann wird sich die frage ergeben wer
wird zuerst geimpft es werden sicherlich
die risikogruppen seien und das
medizinische personal wahrscheinlich
und ja diese fragen werden dann alle
aufkommen und sicherlich wird dann nicht
sofort das problem gelöst sein sondern
selbst wenn wir einen sehr effektiven
impfstoff haben den man vielleicht in
kurzer zeit nur ein oder zweimal impfen
muss und der eine längere immunität
auslöst
das wäre ja der beste fall selbst dann
kann man ja nicht in kurzer zeit alle
menschen durch impfen und ne also das
heißt dass maske tragen und so weiter
wird uns noch eine weile begleiten
mehrere user unter anderem waldfee 123
und auch alexander schmitz machen sich
gedanken darüber wie es sein kann dass
das verfahren was den impfstoff an geht
offenbar so kurz nur ist wenn es
tatsächlich anfang nächsten jahres schon
einen impfstoff geben sollte geht da die
schnelligkeit zu lasten der sicherheit
nein sicherlich nicht also die behörden
sind ganz klar und signalisieren dass
auch hoffentlich klar nach außen und wir
wissen dass wir beobachten das ja auch
sehr genau
es ist so dass die behörden eben nicht
jetzt verkürzte verfahren machen und
dann in kauf nehmen dass die sicherheit
leidet und der impfstoff möglicherweise
nebenwirkungen hat die man dann erst im
lauf entdecken wird sondern es wird
sicherlich so sein dass der impfstoff
genauso in den zulassungs oder einen
probe verfahren geht wie jeder andere
impfstoff oder wie jedes andere
medikament auch da kann man sich sehr
sicher sein wir haben das ja gesehen
jetzt in den letzten tagen gab es ja die
meldung dass auch die erste impfstoff
studie mit der box vor dem stoff kurz
angehalten wurde weil es zwei fälle
gegeben hat einer möglichen
nebenwirkungen also das ist ja glaube
ich evident dass das dann auch greift
die mechanismen die in so einer in so
eine erprobung dann auch stattfinden und
die behörden überwachen das sehr eng
gerade in diesem fall jetzt ein neuer
ansatz so war jetzt zu lesen ist die
passive impfung bei der ja bereits
fertige antikörper also die nicht er
körper dann es selbst bilden muss
sondern fertige antikörper gespritzt
werden ist das aus ihrer sicht
vielversprechend ja die passiv impfung
ist ja immer bei so neu auftretenden
infektionserkrankungen wie zum beispiel
damals auch bei ebola vor einigen jahren
ist ja immer eine mögliche strategie
sehr schnell ein medikament zu haben
das bedeutet dass man antikörper aus
serien von geheilten patienten die die
infektion überstanden haben entnimmt und
dann besonders gute antikörper
herausfiltert und dann testet da gab es
jetzt kürzlich die publikation aus
berlin
die kollegen haben das getestet in einem
hamster modell in einem infektions
modell und jetzt geht es weiter und so
eine substanz oder so ein antikörper
kann dann jetzt in der klinische prüfung
gehen wenn er entsprechend produziert
werden kann
in ausreichenden mengen und dann wird
sich zeigen ob das sicher ist und ob der
entsprechend auch infektionen verhindern
kann oder abmildern kann
und ja das ist eine strategie der
antiviralen medikamente die aktuell
jetzt geprüft werden
das ist also sozusagen das thema impfung
wie es denn eigentlich der stand der
dinge bei medikamenten also bei der
behandlung von infizierten wie weit ist
die wissenschaft da ja mittlerweile gibt
es zwei therapieansätze die jetzt auch
von allen fachgesellschaften empfohlenen
sind und dafür zugelassen sind
das ist einmal das mdc wir das ist ein
antivirale medikament was gezeigt hat
dass insbesondere bei schwer erkrankten
patienten die sterblichkeit gesenkt
werden kann und eine zweite strategie
ist ein kortisonpräparat zu geben was
auch gerade bei schwer erkrankten
patienten diese schwere entzündungen im
körper und in der lunge abmildern kann
und das sind die aktuellen
therapiestrategien und dann gibt es
natürlich ganz viele weitere die jetzt
in der klinischen prüfung sind unter
anderem tun wir das auch in gießen wir
erforschen ein wenig oder haben
erforscht ein medikament was den die
immun lage in der lunge deutlich
verbessert und gleichzeitig die
reparatur des geschädigten organs der
geschädigten lunge vorantreibt und da
beginnen wir jetzt mit den ersten tests
und wollen die ersten patienten noch
einschließen
vielleicht eine ganz schöne schlussfrage
von matrix 99 wann werden wir 100
prozent frei von corona sein
das ganz einfach zu beantworten das
werden wir nie
das virus wird jetzt oder ist in die
humane bevölkerung der population
eingegangen und wird da jetzt auch
weiter zirkulieren das kann man nicht
mehr realisieren das ist da das ist aber
auch nicht schlimm denn wenn wir eine
gewisse grund immunität in der
bevölkerung irgendwann einmal haben
durch eine durchimpfung und auch nur
durch entsprechende durchseuchung also
wenn viele menschen irgendwann mal die
infektion auch durchgemacht haben dann
wird es nicht mehr schlimm sein und wir
kennen das ja von anderen coronaviren es
gibt ja auch vier verschiedene humane
coronaviren die sonate
erkältungskrankheit machen vor allem bei
kindern und wenig spektakulär verlaufen
also ein wenn wir dann irgendwann mal
uns lange genug mit dem virus
auseinandergesetzt haben wird das auch
nicht mehr so tragisch sein wir werden
eben nicht mehr
diese wellen anwohner oder großen zahlen
dann intensiv aufnahmen haben die uns
jetzt vor dem wir jetzt so angst haben
ja und das wird uns aber immer begleiten
und wird dann teil unseres alltags
bleiben
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für das
gespräch frau professor herold von der
universität gießen vielen dank dass sie
bei uns waren hier im studio
natürlich gibt es unendlich viele fragen
zu diesem thema wir konnten jetzt nur
einige anreißen hoffen aber trotzdem
dass wir ein bisschen zur aufklärung
beitragen konnten auch euch vielen dank
für eure fragen und kommentare wir
wünschen euch einen schönen abend ein
schönes wochenende und sagen bis zum
nächsten mal